e
all right the time being 5 P one we'll
get started with today's
meeting I think it's been almost a year
since uh we last met and um our last
report we we uh covered I think five or
six different categories and in in that
last meeting we we decided that uh
really it was just the education
scholarship fund
uh tax credit I should say that we
wanted to um take up this year so
um what I will do is um we'll start by
matter thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee um I'm Jennifer Ramsey I'm
tax policy Council for the Department of
Revenue
Administration as I think you all know
each year we publish a tax expenditure
and potential liability report and the
numbers I'm going to share with you are
from the report that was issued in
December of
2023 uh the uh education tax credit
allows a business organization business
Enterprise or individual to make a money
donation of up to
$600,000 to an approved scholarship
organization and receive a tax credit
against the business profits tax
business Enterprise tax or interest in
dividends tax equal to 85% of the
donation the program is capped currently
at
5100000 in
credits and there's a five-year carry
forward provision for the business
profits tax and the business Enterprise
tax only that began in July of 2018 18
this tax is not a cascading credit if
you know what I mean by that so uh it
may be taken against the business
profits tax or the business Enterprise
tax or the interest in dividends tax but
a credit taken against the business
Enterprise tax is not
treated as tax paid for purposes of the
business profits
tax um last year 118 taxpayers um used
the credit to offset a tax liability of
one of the three taxes for a total of
credit uh thank you you don't have that
in a form that you could pass out to us
do you I didn't bring it with me but it
is on the website and I can send it via
email so everyone has a copy if that'd
be helpful okay that would be helpful um
how does 2 million 256,000 in credits
compared to the last two or three years
uh in 2022 the credits were a million
545,000 in 2021 they were a,
372,000 okay so um do we know is there
any particular reason why in in 23 it it
jumped up so
high there's not a reason that I'm aware
of for the reason for the jump the
um the interest in dividends tax
provision was added in 2018 so it
wouldn't be a the addition of the tax
of question yes thank you but there
seems to be a a a consistency the how
how about the number of people that are
using this credit the number of people
that are using the credit seems to have
stayed fairly stable so it was 110 in
2020 116 in 20121 and 120 in 2022
compared to 118 last year so you you got
a A Very consistent patent here in terms
and which tax are they are they using it
against so they they can use the credit
against any of the three taxes yes I
don't have the detail on which tax um
specifically was comprises the
2,256 million uh 20 2,
256,000 but I can get that and provide
that as well for the F the question yeah
yeah sure yeah that's that so so this
could be an individual or a
business correct okay thank you thank
you Mr
chair
your mic isn't
you besides this financial information
information does uh Dr have any other
information about how
the the scholarship money that results
from the donations that lie behind this
um
are um being Prov who's getting them
what the performances is there any any
information Beyond this financial
information that Dr
collects I I would again need to double
check there is a list of qualified
scholarship programs I believe in order
for a taxpayer to claim the credit they
have to disclose the scholarship program
that the donation was made to I don't
know if we compile the statistics on
which programs are receiving the
majority of the donations it's
information we probably have I don't
know if it's in information we could
disclose due to the confidentiality
obligations that we have I I um I
believe it is true that um Department of
Education I could be wrong about this uh
it collects data has
data that um does provide some of that
information about who the the kids are
um and where they're going uh um what uh
particular schools or categories of
schools I think they're actually named
um are out there and um so I I think I
just apparently Dr doesn't have this
information we've got to ask about it uh
because I think one of our obligations
here is to look at the purposes of these
credits and to see whether they're uh as
used uh for helping to to further that
stated purpose I had uh uh Kate Baker
scheduled she's the chair of the
scholarship fund to be here I'm hoping
that she arrives soon because those are
questions she may be able to answer um I
noticed Jennifer just walked out of the
room but I she maybe she could contact
her
um in the meantime are there other
questions
this is an underservice fund at this
point right it's C at $6 million with
allowing a carry to forward each year um
but and but the annual is $5 million but
we're not anywhere near that at this
point yeah the annual cap is
5,00,000 and we're the people have not
utilized H you know less than half the
y pa again the the the fund
doesn't this only applies to the people
that actually take it so even though we
earmark up to $5 million the fact that
we only had $2.2
million that's all that's an effect that
is $2.2 million on the business interest
the business taxes or the interest in
dividends taxes no we don't take the
full $5 million out only the amount of
credits actually issued that's correct
we we report and the statistic that I
provided you is the amount of
um potential tax that was foregone
um do we I guess this is a copy of what
you have that we have now
sorry correct and I think the the
information I just provided you I think
yeah so the cap is 5 million and we're
one two three four we have four years of
data
here even the highest year not even
okay
um right now we're trying to reach uh
okay okay to answer she said she had it
on the wrong calendar date I'm trying to
find out if she's gonna if she's in
conquering and come over or she is out
of the out of the town and can't make it
I will say this to I just did a quick
uh she's going to head here right now
office confence oh what does that mean
minutes if she can come it certainly
saves us the potential of having another
meeting what's that she says she's in
her office I think her office is here in
conquer I don't know and if it is then
she's on her
way she's has an answer me back second
okay I just did I asked her like within
the next 15 minutes and I'm waiting to
see if she answers me she said she can
head here now she's in her office but I
far
in
who put that report out is that a
of
does anyone have any other questions of
point if you don't mind hanging around a
little bit we'll just we're hoping that
uh Kate Baker is going to show up soon
and could trigger other questions but
I'm happy to hang around and if there's
a such a thing as a scholarship
organization report that I'm able to get
my hands on I'm going to look for that
while we're waiting perfect thank you
thank
you yeah I I have to apologize I'm only
at Dr a couple of months and still
learning what information I actually
have available so I will I will look as
we'll uh we'll recess for 10 minutes
until
1:30
e
okay the time being 1:32 we'll come back
from our
recess and
um we'll invite
uh we'll invite Kate Baker
up thank you very much for uh on short
um can you put your microphone I tried
to bring stories of your own
constituents for you um
for um the senator I brought up you'll
see a a story of a family from
Manchester who's participating so I
that otherwise um I know you reviewed
already with Dr all the data do you have
any specific questions for me that you'd
like to ask uh we did have um questions
to drill down into the data a little bit
wonderful uh representative Ames I think
you had some questions you would like to
ask hi representative Ames how are you
well how are you pleasure to see you
I'll turn my mic on and you can hear me
um good to see you too yeah so
um this is a revisit for me and I'm sure
for others on the progress of this
program over the
years um and what I uh was trying to get
at but we really um didn't needed help
uh um
[Music]
was looking behind the the
numbers
to
what's actually happening um as I look
look uh I'm wondering whether you've got
an audit program or whether there's any
uh way of checking on whether expenses
that are charged this program are within
the Ambit or something things that are
excluded by Statute from that's right
yeah you can't use this program for
transportation right or the parents time
in homeschooling um if you notice from
the list in the department of revenue
report this is a predominantly School
tuition program where the family applies
to a particular private school the
private school tells us the tuition the
family owes and then we calculate a
scholarship at after that on the rest of
their tuition Due based on the Family's
income depending on what bracket they
fit in so our lowest income families
those um free lunch income level
families will get a 75% scholarship
based on the tuition that they
owe after their school financial aid so
imagine you're going to a little lowcost
uh you know montauri school and the
tuition is six
$6,000 and you f into that 75% bracket
or let me just do 50% bracket so it's
easy for my mind and the school has no
internal financial aid you're going to
get a scholarship from us to cover half
of that tuition or
$3,000 remember the Department of
Revenue well the legislature set in this
law some caps for the scholarships so
the average of all the scholarships
together has to be under about $3,000 is
what the cap is it started at about 27
00 and it's been increasing by CPI every
year and so the average scholarship is
about $3,000 per kid remember and that's
all lumped together and we calculate
them individually based on the students
need it works wonderfully we've come in
under the cap every year because we have
a diverse group of families that range
from you know very very low income to
more moderate income remember this
program's income limits are 300% of the
poverty line or below so it's targeted
to really low and moderate income
families that have more tuition needs
than this school can
support uh to follow up uh what
information do you have that tells you
and that uh we could learn about the
performance of
students um who
are um helped by the aid under this
program so usually it's by looking at
the performance of the schools so if you
look at these little private schools in
New Hampshire for example if you take
the Catholic schools as an example the
kids in those schools average about 85th
percentile at grade level or above so
those private schools look very similar
to what the town of Bedford looks like
in their academic achievement scores so
the department of Ed collects those
scores or the schools put them on their
websites but that's how you would know
what the children are doing in the
choosing you know the department of Ed
monitors the private schools and
approves them for activities to
exist Does the Department of Education
have any monitoring responsibilities
with with respect to this program this
is monitored by the Department of
Revenue only yes I see well the
Department of Education has only the
perview over so remember this program
originally was designed for what they
call
switchers kids going from public school
to private school the department of
education does verify those scids to
make sure that the children meet that
requirement and it's a certain
percentage of the students in the group
that have to be going from public to
private and I think again the
legislature created it that way so it
would be Revenue
neutral you know they would know that
there's a cost savings for those kids to
offset any minus from the tax credit
that you guys see yes yeah so they do
oversee that
piece I'll leave it at that thank you
questions questions well I have a
question just to comment I'm looking at
this department of Ed form whatever the
number is Department of Revenue the ed5
yeah that's the Department of Revenue
that's a report we file annually with
the Department of Revenue they're
actually on that website Department of
revenues website all the way back to
2013 you can see the from when we
started with a whole what 50 kids I
think yeah so so for me when I'm looking
at this we're talking about one of the
reasons where we have this committee
meeting is talk about the efficacy how
how efficient how how is it being used
is it is it good for the State of New
Hampshire and the citizens of the State
of New Hampshire and I'm drawn on page
three to specifically the last two
questions enf on this form and it says
you know my child seen measurable
improvements in academic achievement
right out of roughly 1100 people that
responded over a thousand of them
strongly agree or agree that their child
seeing academic Improvement and then I
look at F you know my child would not be
able to attend the school of his or her
choice without this credit program and
again out of roughly 1100 students over
a thousand are saying without this
program my kid couldn't have that
academic performance that they're seeing
so as a general rule I I just think that
this is doing exactly what we intended
it to do right we want to provide choice
to allow kids that were being challenged
in public schools to have an opportunity
and we're seeing exactly by the
responses of the citizens the parents
who have these kids in the schools that
this is in fact functioning as we
intended so well and I know too the
people that are donating to the program
and utilizing the credit are very
pleased that they can direct you know
their tax dollars specifically to
children's education I know that's
something that's really important to the
people contributing the in fact new
money right this is money that otherwise
wouldn't necessarily go to education
these are donors saying I would like my
money to go to education making a
donation and using the credit um I know
that that for them is a very important
piece of this that they're having the
opportunity to fund children either in
their own communities or or Statewide in
communities where there's a lot of need
like I know we find a lot of children in
Claremont but not a lot of donors in
Claremont right and so sometimes the
donors in Claremont will come from hover
or New London to help those kids in
Claremont so I I just think it's a it's
a great way to enable contributions to
kids specifically for education in New
Hampshire and I know the people
contributing appreciate the opportunity
that um at one point you mentioned if I
heard it correctly I think you said the
cap was around 3.1 million so the cap
total contributions that we could
receive is actually 6 million a year
okay and the cap on the credits is 85%
of that so what is it 5.2 million um we
still have not reached that cap in
donations I we do a good job fundraising
we're running all over the state talking
to people but I mean it is only
fundraising in New Hampshire and so
getting to two or three million a year
seems to be what we can do with our two
people that are doing the fundraising if
I had was able to hire more fundraisers
I probably could get to that cap of 6
million but remember for each one of
these we're visiting with the donor
asking them to contribute to education
in their community and then they're
agreeing to so it really is a
fundraising job in that regard so okay
so the cap you were referring to was
more a cap on just ability based on the
fact you don't have much so what I was
talking about is in the law there's a
few metrics that we have to meet which
is why this report is so important every
year
one of them is that the average
scholarship which is all the
scholarships added together that we give
out put together and averaged has to be
equal to X and that number is set by the
Department of Revenue every year based
on the Consumer Price Index and this
year you can see the average scholarship
this past year right on this blue sheet
it was
$3,023 and then the average homeschool
scholarship was around $1,000 so those
are metrics set by the law the other
metrics are 40% of the children have to
be in the free and reduced lunch income
level bracket and we never struggle
meeting that metric because of course
families that are coming to us seeking
scholarship assistance need it right so
they're overwhelmingly lower income
families um and the other metric is the
number of children leaving public school
going to private school and again I
think the legislature did that to make
it Revenue neutral knowing that a child
moving to a private school you using
this money wasn't costing their you know
town the cost to educate them or the
state adequate education grant
money does that help those are the
metrics yeah thank you yes represent
Ames um the interest in dividends tax is
going
away and um my question is uh What
proportion of uh scholarship money has
come
from against that tax yeah not very much
un fortunately I wish it was more it was
only about
$200,000 total so yes we'll have to
hustle and find new businesses that are
paying the business Enterprise or
profits tax to donate in the place of
those few interest and dividends tax
credit donors but it I it didn't do what
I think as much as you guys thought it
might have done again people just don't
know about it it's
existence so it won't have very big of
an impact so so that it sounds like
based on the number you just said it
represents maybe 10% of the total the
total last year was 3.4 million that we
raised and it was um only about1 or
$200,000 of it yeah so we should be able
to make that up with hustling and and
finding new people that pay the other
taxes business taxes to take the make a
donation right sounds good s l uh no
just about the children going back to
the kids um how many um how do you turn
away applicants either due to financials
and does that look like yes we we need
to raise more money every year there's
more applications than we can meet for
example this past year um it was about
600 children that we couldn't help
because we didn't raise enough money so
yes there's more demand again if I had
another fundraiser I think it we could
get closer to that so I'm thinking about
trying to decide if I should hire
another person to work with us to try to
raise more money to help more kids
because there's always more demand than
we can meet so that there was understand
what you just said so there was 600 kids
that met the low poverty level or work
but I call Working Poor level um that
you were unable to serve because of no
Financial availability cor yeah yeah we
run out of money every year and have to
that's the hardest part of the job
actually I mean you'd think fundraising
was the hardest part of the job but
actually getting to the end and finding
that there's people that you can't give
a scholarship to is the hardest part of
the job yeah but it just feels my fire
uh Senator Lang to get out there and and
find more people that want to
contribute to the scholarships right
welcome any other question yes so one
more thing again so but you rais it's a
75% right 85% 85% so we would raise you
would get a donation that was equivalent
of a million dollars in education
dollars but the person only gets credit
from the state for 850,000 so we get an
extra 15% of available money for
Education that we would otherwise not
have that's correct yes because
someone's giving me the whole amount and
then they're only taking a credit on p a
it I question M related to that um
there's also a federal tax credit that
these businesses and individuals can
take as I understand it they talking
about that in the um Congress but it
hasn't passed
yet I thought I I would have thought
that the
uh uh an individual or a business for
that matter that makes a donation to a
oh you're talking about if it's a
charitable contribution yes they can get
a deduction for a charitable contribu
top of the someone could do that
85% yeah most people don't do that
because they're not itemizing I think
the way the new tax law is that
charitable contributions are not very
beneficial right now well if they if
they are beneficial to a particular
individual then essentially they can get
up pretty close to their dollar they
they might be able to if you're in say
that um a 20% tax bracket and you donate
$10,000 your deduction so it's different
than a credit you know this right a
credit would be a minus the deduction
from your taxable income would be what
$2,000 on 10 right because you're in the
20% bracket yeah yeah
yeah and there are some people to your
question who just donate regular money
to us without a tax credit don't doubt
it
yeah thank you so much for having me
yeah thank you for
coming any other any other questions for
either Dr or scholarship
fund do we feel like we have enough
conclusions Mr chair if I may yeah my
recommendation is to make no
recommendation on changes to this
program I think it's functioning exactly
as it's intended to we as I talked about
the important metrics to me uh are the
are students performing better than they
would if they didn't have this
alternative and are they are they able
to get this alternative because it's AA
able to them and the answer to both
those was yes they wouldn't have this if
we didn't have this program in place and
they wouldn't have had the improvements
if this program was it in place and so I
I think the credit's doing exactly what
it's uh supposed to do I'd recommend
that we not change a single
thing I would agree with that anyone
else uh representative Ames your
microphone is on so I'm assuming you
want to your microphone is on would you
like to say something about oh yeah well
if it's on maybe I should say
so
um you know uh the reports that we've
looked at are uh
informative
um at
a fairly high level of uh of looking at
it all um the
U and the picture is of kids that are in
relatively poor families that are um
getting
help in private schools um one part of
that picture is that the private schools
without having done a calculation I
don't know are significantly if nothing
more um religious just by their very
name um
and
um
that is an aspect aspect of this program
that um that concerns many people the
great degree to which it is
um providing some level of public
support uh I paused on that I'll come
back to that uh for Religious
Education and uh we have very little
information on the actual education goes
inside the doors so have to be cautious
on even describing it that way but uh
uh there's that aspect of it and
um and
so so I don't disagree with with
um not putting any qualifications on our
support other than to say that uh um to
report if we could get the detail the
proportion of kids that are in private
schools I'd love to include in religious
schools I'd love to include that
the proportion of kids that are
homeschooled that's another another
um I guess I would leave it at that I
wish we had more information and I
don't I guess I'm not sure feeling
strongly enough about it to push for
that
yes Senator I concur with representative
Ames I think you need more we need more
information uh when you look at the the
numbers and you look at the number of
Christian related schools it gives me
pause now I taught in a parochial school
I taught at Bishop Bradley high school
and I taught at a public school kenned
high school up in Conway so I I I I
think the movement here is toward a
religiously oriented schools well those
schools were all
closing remember we had numerous schools
with a religious affiliation in
Manchester that closed St Anthony's
closed St Mary's close St George's close
close close close close well these are
all now giving an opportunity to re to
revisit their their closure uh Trinity
just put a large addition on $2 million
addition well look at the numbers here
Trinity is getting help through this
through this program not that not that
I'm a a post that but I I just think U
it Bears it bears looking at uh it bears
looking at I thought the comment that
was made by the the lady I thought was
very appropriate but she talked about
Bedford well bedford's a rich Community
a very rich community and and as a
result of that you don't see a lot of
this activity in a town like bedan
because the public school is very
acceptable there spend a lot of money on
the public school and so for
I I would I would like to look
at the public schools where there's a
significant
investment if there's any movement from
that
situation probably not I mean that's
just a guest but then you look at it the
opposite way and I think Clen wants the
great issue and we're in court again
right we're in court as we speak about
it the is is it benefiting those kids I
I don't know
but uh
obviously there are uh there there is a
desire for people to to to move into
this program it's I think the
consistency is about 100 people take
advantage of it and uh obviously at at
85% not a bad deal and not a bad deal if
you can also do it at the federal level
you know that's that's very helpful
so I've
seen the Advent of of uh movement in
education over the years will continue
to see that I think we'll continue to
see that as we as we kind of move move
along just my my comments I think it's
it's interesting to look at the to look
at the data we'll get a little deeper
into the data but what we have
presented to ourselves it it just seems
to be if you use this method sure it's
going to be favorable to you would you
say it was
negative well there are no people did
yeah yeah there some yeah a thousand
said yes and and five said no there's
always one in the crow come on you when
you get 99% that say yes I'd say it's uh
yeah it's it is it is it is what it is
and it is what it is but thank you I
mean when she one minute when she said
uh when she brought Bedford into the
conversation it was my understanding
that you know in General Bedford
students are high performing and this
this group was performing at that level
I don't think she was talking about
anything other than performance
level that may be so but B spends the
most
money yeah the point well the point is
but the point the point of the matter is
I think they got a beautiful school they
have a beautiful athletic programs they
spent a ton of money a ton of money and
the and and the mediate family income in
benefit is almost $200,000 a year you
think they're going to have good schools
no but I'm not arguing that point I'm
just saying what she's saying is the
level of um academic achievement they're
saying is
high representative do said Yeah just
something I noted was there seems to be
a lot of talk about uh homeschooling but
the numbers for the homeschooled kids
here are 100 at 110 I thought I saw in
comparison so we can take AP our
components what what what uh we're
seeing is there's a positive effect for
the kids at the end of the day there's a
positive effect for the kids it's done
in a cost effective way
and the job at hand is getting the kids
the best education and it's happening
under the program so it's working well I
wouldn't change right a
thing and go ahead so again I I I don't
want to get into the policy discussion
of whether we should exclude religious
schools or not I don't know that that's
the function of this committee the
function of the committee is we have a
tax expenditure program and is the
program's goal is to support
underprivileged children who give them
additional educational Choice um and and
and have a metric for whether or not
performance is is improved I think we
heard from Kate that the the uh from uh
Dr Baker that they use a metric from
doed to approve organizations that have
a certain performance level kidss are
meeting at 85% or above on performance
level for an ed for those that that
school to be eligible for uh those this
program and so again I think
continuously the question is are we
providing for the citizens of New
Hampshire value for their dollars as it
relates to education and everything I've
heard says yes um that if we want to
have the policy argu whether you want to
exclude religious schools that's for the
legislature to take up in a different
time but for the purpose of this expend
as it's reported and as it's currently
constituted it is performing well for
our citizens um it's performing well um
we get we get an increased 15% value in
education just by the tax credit by only
being 85% we get a million dollars in
for education and we only have to give a
credit for 850,000 we get a bonus on top
of that from the state for our children
um you know the mere fact that she has
600 kids she has to turn away really
breaks my heart that there's kids still
out there looking for need and looking
for work that we don't have availability
for but that's not what we're here to
solve either right I think this program
is doing what it's meant to do um its
metrics seem to be hitting exactly what
we wanted to do and again I have no
comment I guess I guess um I I want to
see whether this point we want to uh
make a motion on that and and and then
we'll we'll be done we'll write a report
on this um I feel like that's where
we're at but I just want to see where
um if if the members agree on
that I'll make a motion that we that we
make no recommended changes to this
program second second by
discussion I I kind I agree with the
recommendation I think the program is
what the program is but let's look at
somebody should be looking at the
program a little more seriously look at
the data and and look at the
preponderance of religious
schools and I I think that's that's
important that that's important uh
and somehow some way
U look at that
as how it fits into into the mix uh
we're we're as as we speak we're
currently involved in a very
serious legal challenge to public
education and how public education is
funded that challenge has been accepted
by the Supreme Court we uh the state has
to defend its position a superior court
judge has said that we
underfund public education by about
50% he says we need another 500 billion
uh for public schools if you read the
decision I'm not sure you've all read
the decision well that's a that's a lot
of money compared to to what we're
expending here you know that's that's
that's a significant jump and and we'll
have to see how that uh how how that
work works out but I think it's it's
clear or it's clear to me we have
problems with the way we deal with
public
education and the way we Finance public
education I've been around here for a
long time I was on the committee of
conference in 1999 when we settled the
Claremont decision you when we came up
with the possible solution uh so that's
been around the long long long time uh
and U we we we we're going to have to
revisit a lot of things in the next
legislative
session thank you Mr chairman thank you
um I think the other piece of d dat that
I'm looking at as well is that the cap
is 5.1 5.2 million we're only at 2.2 and
when you look at the last few years it
bounced I mean it was 1.9 million two
years ago then it was 1 point I don't
have it right in front of me now 1.4 1.5
then 2.2 we're not talking about huge
numbers here I think at this point um to
to go ahead and and say that you know
this program is working um you're not
looking at huge numbers right now and it
[Music]
think okay I'll say again when I write
up the notes I'll make sure this all the
committee reports like you can go back I
got the ones from the previous years
right so the minutes are all included
anybody wants to review and see what
discussions were the recommendations end
up just being a summary of here's what
we end up coming to a con conclusion not
the
right I mean yeah definitely no need to
increase and we're not even halfway
there so dick I don't know if you
remember when I was in the onways me I
was the one that actually put a cap on
this was an unlimited tax credit
originally um we put the $5 million
credit on by my by my Amendment um I
don't remember his last ter with
before no no it was it had and that's
what I was afraid of um so I was nervous
with a no UNCA tax cred um and so we
talked we talked with uh with da we
talked with with Kate and we came up
with the $5 million number that was
reasonable and because we knew it was
only about $1 million about one point
1.8 I think it was somewhere around
there so we paid a a $5 million cap deal
with the future we don't have to worry
shape it's a half on the total number of
credits that can issue for any for
totally regardless of where it falls
they can
issue
yeah but that's a total number across
the state total number across the entire
State it's it's a so the maximum we will
ever have a reduction in revenue is $5.1
million right that's the maximum
reduction we can
get is it directly against the tax or is
it a so they get so so correct me if I'm
wrong but I think I'm right on this they
basically get get a the the donor gets a
a check not a virtual check saying hey
you get you know you you donated uh
$10,000 to this uh program you get an
$88,500 tax credit when you submit your
tax bill you know you can apply this
credit to taxes owned and then if they
owe $10,000 in credit they only write
$1,500 check and their taxes are covered
well yeah there there's nothing wrong
with that but it'll be a small very
small
it ended up being a very small it was up
to a couple
hundred, on
a yeah it was probably roughly 5% of the
total and
she and she felt very confident that she
could um raise enough money from the
business profit from the business
profits and business Enterprise tax
okay um if there's no other discussion
we'll uh call for a vote
I all in
favor okay 5 zero to leave it the
same very good so you're write and
sounds good we're
done we all done um the year for the
year that's that's it good thank you
everyone
e